joining us now Speaker of the House
Kevin McCarthy
how are you
[Applause]
you don't keep your promises I will be
the first person to call you out did I
not say that yes you did and you've held
me accountable you put me on the show
numerous times you you laid out exactly
what we've already passed and what we're
going to do later this week we got our
border security bill being marked up
this week and next week we've got a debt
ceiling bill look at our house fiscally
in order we're going to send that over
to the Senate next week we're going to
limit we're going to save and we're
going to grow because we're going to put
America in a much stronger position we
made a commitment to America and we're
going to keep it and that includes the
parents Bill of Rights that includes
restoring intelligence committee to
safeguard National Security to defund 87
IRS agents I want to ask you about the
debt ceiling so we expect that to come
due sometime in June are you saying to
me that the president has not spoken to
you in 75 days the guy that once said it
can't be my way of the highway Joe Biden
said that are you saying he's not even
negotiating with you like he said he
wouldn't not at all he he told the
Democrats he's going to negotiate with
me told me at a prayer breakfast he was
going to negotiate with me and the only
time I've seen him he wouldn't talk
about the debt ceiling he doesn't want
to talk about the death did he remember
your name why you see a real problem
here in the next 10 years we're going to
have to pay 10.5 trillion dollars just
in interest but to put that in
perspective since 1940 and today we've
only had to pay 9 trillion interest in
80 some years they spent six trillion
dollars and added in the last little bit
that's what caused inflation that's what
caused our banking crisis that's what
caused problems just like this country
so they're gonna they're gonna claim
Republicans that the full faith and
credit of the US government is hanging
in the balance meanwhile they won't talk
to you now you have a majority 222
Republicans you're going to have to be a
United majority you're willing to
increase the debt ceiling you're not
demanding that we balance the budget
immediately which would be
mathematically impossible but you are
going to have a list of Demands well all
222 Republicans stay strong and say no
debt ceiling increase unless we get a b
c and d is that going to happen
that's exactly why we're meeting our
conference tomorrow it has to otherwise
we can't get there I call it a
three-prong plan we're going to limit
save and grow we're going to limit the
amount that government can spend going
in the future what we'll do is just the
next 10 years will only increase funding
each year by one percent we're going to
save we're going to pull back that covet
money that was unspent if you
appropriated the money for the pandemic
but the pandemic is over you shouldn't
spend it now we're going to grow our
economy pass HR one that we went through
make us energy independent reform the
red tape that will allow us to build
things in America again this is just a
small sample of what we can do and we'll
raise the debt limit because we'll be
able to save more money grow the economy
and make America stronger yeah all right
Kevin McCarthy for every single promise
you keep we will give you credit if you
don't keep them I'm going to yell at you
all right hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews most compelling analysis you
will not get it anywhere else